it's just phenomenally beautiful are you
were like at that stage I was pretty
much broken gorilla does that is the
best news we've had for hours
we all just
[Music]
this is a particular subspecies of
gorilla it's known as the King Kong
but the biggest ape there is
[Music]
it is unique to this particular region
isn't that amazing
in the middle of war-torn DRC there is
this particular subspecies of gorilla
that you cannot find anywhere else in
the world there are very few left they
only live in one particular part and
they are under serious threat now from
poaching
the gorilla is being targeted
it's under so much pressure it stands to
be extinct in one generation you've gone
from a thriving population to literally
hundreds left
unfortunately for the gorilla it's right
in the middle of a water
knowing what I know now about the DRC I
would say that is a very risky trip it's
a dangerous place and there are armed
militia groups everywhere and you just
don't know when that danger is going to
arrive there is still quite a lot of
militant groups in the area and these
militant groups will throw roadblocks
and you never know quite know what's
going to happen whether they're just
going to extort some money where they're
going to take you hostage but you can
never tell once you get into the forest
thing you're gonna meet it's right in
the middle of unstable government it's
right in the middle of poverty which
means that the guerrilla is one of the
main targets the successive wars that
they've had in this part of the world
have meant that various fighting groups
have lived in these forests and have
killed the guerrillas to eat and also
for sale and the villagers have very
little money and very little way of
making money
if you're poor and you kill a gorilla
that could feed a whole village for a
week it's out of poverty that they've
been reduced to killing the gorilla
because it represented a lot of meat a
lot of meat and most of these people
just don't eat from day to day
never mind have meat
[Music]
Cosi be a good national park is assumed
it's National Park in eastern Democratic
Republic of Congo you fly into small
Airport then you have to take a ferry
along boat journey across the lake which
was amazing is just phenomenally
beautiful the Rangers are specifically
there to protect the gorillas one of
ways of trying to save the gorillas is
that they go out and find the best
poachers and convinced them to become
Rangers one of the Rangers that was with
us was just such a poacher who'd been
converted the great thing about these
guys is that they know poachers and they
know where they operate how they operate
and they're much more effective at
combating militia groups our poaching so
the Rangers are armed they know where
the families of gorillas are and they go
on patrol to protect them
they don't want to be taken hostage and
many of them have a whole load of them
were held hostage for three weeks before
they were freed it's a very scary job
for them to do very scary by being there
we were targets if they could find a
foreigner to kidnap we were with the
Rangers
we represent money basically
it's not a very safe place and will it
be mainly like this where there's open
light or will it get dark our forest
she's really close in 30 see how long do
you think we're gonna walk for till we
find them I think we set out with really
high hopes
katenka queer game of it it depends a
plus we found them exhibitors is very
often fantastic good mm-hmm
litters and out cool you get to the dust
warm of jungle that sort of meets you
and as you disappear into the jungle
your hopes are high that you will see
something soon
like to get in the way of those machetes
the Ranger said don't worry I think if
if we're lucky we can find the
guerrillas within maybe an hour or so we
set off with quite high hopes of seeing
a family of gorillas pretty quickly
no they told us their trackers out
already and they knew where they were
going okay one way kill my little girl
you'll kill him without everybody good
and up though he was here reality was
something different it was thick thick
thick and it's damp so regardless of
whether it's rained or noise just damp
so we were falling over we were sliding
around thank you
slipping around fooling tripping those
branches some you had to climb over
there were thick layers of vines
everywhere
climbing up cliffs with this steep and
going down cliffs look with this steep
[Music]
are you alright
the number of times we slipped down both
of us slipped down all of us slip down
trying to find these things and we
didn't see anything and occasionally we
would stop and the Rangers went to scout
off to see if they could see any sign of
them where are they
come back we're saying oh just a bit
further just a bit further um it went on
just seemingly forever that's for sure
at the same time is trying to claw your
way through this undergrowth and the
vines we were trying to film as well
you've got soldiers with guns and
Rangers with machetes and we thought
right this is visually you know really
quite dramatic but after a while we
realized that this was going on for so
long that we had to just conserve our
energy and our batteries it was quite
hard to try and make your way through
the undergrowth carrying the camera
trying to keep it from getting wet or
getting covered in mud it's quite
challenge hallux would turn to camera
and say something to me actually isn't a
floor it's just a massive violence isn't
it
if you put your foot in the wrong place
oh I'd ask you a question
tell me you're not like of the rest yeah
it's timely we kind of have that as we
were going along thinking this would be
a nice sequence hard-going gorilla dung
that is the best news we've had for
hours they then became a joke some of
Alex's replies were quite short mmm
things aren't looking too good to be
honest we were trying to see humor in
this dark moment because we were really
tired you're following the route where
you think they are and then you longer
this walk just went on and on and on at
that stage I was pretty much broken and
my main concern was no longer gorillas
but how I was going to survive another
four hours getting out of the jungle
light was fading our hope was definitely
fading and I had visions of helicopters
having to winch me out because I was
completely toast at that stage checking
in the jungle in DRC is not for the
faint hives fortunately it turned out we
were only having gone in
area circles we were only half an hour
from the edge of the forest stay light
still we were exhausted and we hadn't
seen a single gorilla sweaty wet dusty
muddy trousers we didn't see next day
they said don't worry we're gonna go
ahead we'll send some Scouters out ahead
they'll find where they are we'll take
you straight there for me the idea of
going back and doing another four hours
of that sort of struggle through the
jungle was a bit tortuous the Rangers
made us put on these these masks and the
mask is to protect the gorillas yes of
course sometimes you can use indeed they
don't good we set off with heavy hearts
wondering whether we were going to see
anything at all but you've got to do it
we had to find the gorillas that's what
we were there for they seemed pretty
confident we'll get closer to the others
time
[Music]
I didn't think a cloud it was Nick who
saw them first
I was towards the back of the group and
as they were walking through I just saw
a gorilla walk across our path guys
there's a gorilla there we couldn't
believe we'd only just set off they were
so well camouflaged these huge creatures
I wasn't quite sure what I was looking
at so shake here they were literally
barely close to us and just hiding
behind the tree and then you realize
I've here to do a job you know I've got
us then start shooting pictures I just
wanted to sit there and watch them then
we saw the silverback he was huge my
first impression was that it looked like
a man in a gorilla suit because he
looked they looked so preposterous
Liebig exactly like you'd think a man in
a gorilla suit would be like but this
one was real and he just sat there
chewing and looking at us this creature
could become extinct
some say he could be gone in as little
as five years and it's all down to
humans actually the lens makes it look
like they're further away it felt like
he was breathing down my neck all of a
sudden I was behind and the silverback
was a few meters away and just like oh
my gosh oh my gosh blue bang we all just
it was terrifying and I just saw this
wall of people's jump back and the
ranger explained that they was just
making us aware that he was the boss and
that we were to not step out of line and
we were very careful not to
[Music]
just the presence because the mass of
gorillas is huge it just seems so
enormous or inspiring as well the air
was thick with all the his little mid
jeez
there were swarms of these small flies
everywhere sometimes you wouldn't see
them and then you would touch a plant or
a vine and a whole cloud would come up
and fill the air they were everywhere it
didn't seem to bother the gorillas at
all guys have quickly quickly turned
around which is no easy thing to do
turning your back on a 7-foot gorilla so
we'd be following these one or two
gorillas and difficult to see them and
then all of a sudden we opened out into
this area where there were loads of them
all just sat quite happily eating and
hanging out
we were sitting amongst them we were
like part of her little family grew
one of them was this really small baby
gorilla you could have just cuddled it
in your arms it was just a small into
the little baby one had this really
expressive face the baby was so curious
about us and he was fascinated by the
camera and so he kept on sort of edging
closer and the Ranger was obviously a
little bit nervous and it got really
quite close and we were all he just
reached forward and then the Ranger that
was next to us just doing my little go
to touch he drew back and it was all
really sweet his face was really
expressive you can see he was sat there
sulking but his being told off you don't
like a scolded child I mean it's you see
him and you see the actions that he
makes it's so cute
who is the cutest thing I've ever seen
they've certainly gave you a sense of a
family a sense of characters and a sense
of sharing your world with them
let's say human in their mannerisms we
just wanted to spend the whole day there
[Music]
it felt like a massive privilege it was
such a such a special moment as long
approaching continues the threat to
these gorillas is very real but right on
the edge of the forest we came across a
new project that offers some hope a
coffee plantation
this particular coffee plantation was a
brand new venture what they were doing
was convincing what would be poachers to
then get into the coffee growing
business and have a cash crop that would
give them an income instead of going out
and poaching just describe what what he
used to do you see net broke up in a
novel they used to capsule in a trap the
guys were clearing the ground in between
the coffee plants they had quite a set
up and they showed us around and they
were really very proud of what they've
achieved and what they had created there
generally it's out of poverty that
they've been reduced to killing the
gorillas poison there were so poor that
they really have no choice but to go
into the forest and poach
[Music]
by starting up this coffee plantation
they were trying to encourage people to
put their energy into growing coffee
which would eventually yield something
that they could sell which would give
them money to buy food
[Music]
[Music]
the eastern lowland gorillas are really
threatened now they have a viable number
of them but the pressure from militia
groups and from villages who are hunting
them is so strong still that they are
really quite seriously endangered
without gorillas they won't have any
tourism the tourism is the key which is
quite a difficult sell because of the
militia groups and there's instability
in the area they need tourists in order
to protect the gorillas yes it's in its
infancy and yes there have been problems
but you know DRC is trying to bring more
people in if they can stabilize the area
enough that we can make it a more viable
tourist destination then that will be
the safest way of guaranteeing the
survival of the gorillas
in many African countries we've seen
animals hunted to extinction this could
be another situation where in 50 years
time there and over would but we'd like
to think that with the work of the
Rangers and the government who need to
step in and how
the gorillas can exist in their natural
habitat
[Music]